we tend to define a movie success mostly
by how it performs in American theaters
but big-budget films can live or die by
how well they do overseas still while
Hollywood is becoming more aware of
global audiences there are still plenty
of movies that simply don't go over well
in certain countries consequently some
of your favorite films have been banned
internationally for a variety of reasons
from unanticipated cultural
insensitivity to uncomfortable reminders
of real-life violence here are some
films you've probably seen that were
banned around the world
Kingsman the Golden Circle the biggest
problem for American audiences with
Kingsman the Golden Circle was probably
Channing Tatum's minimal screen time but
the government of Cambodia had a very
different issue according to their
culture ministries film Department the
film's use of Cambodia for the villains
headquarters contributed to the world's
negative impression of Cambodian
organized crime worse the villainous
hideout closely resembles tarp Ram a
well known Cambodian temple the film
setting led to Cambodia completely
banning any screenings but considering
that the Kingsmen series is a pastiche
of James Bond films you could say that
cultural insensitivity is just part of
the genre Zoolander Ben Stiller has a
knack for playing bizarre narcissists
and his role as Derek Zoolander ranks
among the most outlandish from life and
death catwalks to Zoolander getting
brainwashed into trying to assassinate
the Prime Minister of Malaysia the film
is dripping with absurd humor
unfortunately though unsurprisingly some
of that humor didn't quite land with the
Malaysian government which banned the
film from release it wasn't just the
assassination plot that put Zoolander in
hot water it was the reason for it the
Prime Minister is targeted because he
wants to put an end to Malaysian
sweatshops making light of working
conditions was unsurprisingly offensive
to the real Malaysian government and the
film was promptly banned Malaysia wasn't
the only country upset as its neighbour
Singapore also banned it as well you're
dead
[Music]
the wolf of wall street martin
scorsese's the wolf of wallstreet is
packed with drug filled escapades
explicit love making scenes and
colorfully profane dialogue it even
holds the record for the most uses of
the f-word in a non documentary with
five hundred and six instances in total
its excessive in the truest sense and
it's easy to understand how it could
possibly offend audiences it's
unsurprising then that wolf of
wallstreet was censored edited and
banned in multiple countries Nepal and
Malaysia bandit outright while India the
United Arab Emirates and Lebanon all cut
scenes Singapore restricted showings to
less than a dozen theaters but that
didn't stop it from coming in first at
their box office ultimately the film was
a critical and commercial success
despite or perhaps because of the
controversy
[Applause]
Shrek 2 it can be very tricky to
translate comedy into a different
language you have to match the style and
tone of the original while also
adjusting cultural references to ones
that your new audience is more likely to
understand
unfortunately the Hebrew translation of
Shrek 2 contained a jokes so
controversial that the film was banned
in Israel until the line was removed in
the original english-language version a
character threatens to castrate Puss in
Boots new RAM right here
give him the Bob Barker treatment
suspecting that Israeli audiences
wouldn't get the reference the
translation team changed the line -
let's do it David door on him door is an
Israeli singer known for his high voice
but he didn't find the joke funny and he
successfully managed to get a court
order issued that banned the film from
theaters until the offending line was
removed The Hunger Games
there's a very fine line between
tasteful symbolism and straight-up gore
when it comes to depicting violence on
screen while there isn't an objective
answer to where that boundary lies it's
true that the u.s. tends to accept
violence in movies more readily than
other countries Vietnam for instance
band The Hunger Games for its violent
imagery the film's Vietnamese premiere
was delayed before it was ultimately
banned altogether according to the
country's National Film Board the bloody
scenes may be acceptable in America but
in Vietnam they're too violent and
ruthless despite the ban some Vietnamese
fans announced they planned to see the
film in nearby Cambodia or Singapore
Borat and Bruno some films are so
willfully controversial that it's no
surprise when they get banned Sacha
Baron Cohen might be an expert on that
as 2006 is Borat and 2009 s Bruno both
prompted outcry worldwide each film
follows outlandish characters in
outrageous often offensive scenarios
Borat was unsurprisingly banned from
Kazakhstan for its offensive portrayal
of the country of a year
it was also banned in Russia as well as
multiple Arab countries bruno fared
slightly better but not by much
ukraine banned it for its highly
explicit content while malaysia banned
it for pretty much the same reason
despite the bans both films managed to
gross many hundreds of millions
worldwide Deadpool in 2016
Deadpool became the highest-grossing
r-rated movie of all time worldwide
despite a pretty significant handicap it
was denied release in China due to its
extreme levels of violence the film was
deemed to be so constantly violent that
there wasn't any way to censor it while
retaining the plot while it's impressive
that Deadpool made so much without any
Chinese revenue it's a real shame for
Chinese fans who weren't able to see the
Merc with a mouth on the big screen
luckily for a few fortunate film goers
Deadpool eventually did premiere in
China although not as a full release as
it's screened at the 2018 international
Beijing Film Festival
[Music]